in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Michael
and Melissa are with us hey guys how are
ya better than we deserve well how come
good to have you where you from Iowa
City Iowa City Iowa City made the drive
down very very cool so how much debt
have you paid off we paid off at twenty
nine thousand and twenty three thousand
twenty nine thousand and twenty three
separately separately okay so you're
you're a dating couple we are we're
gonna be married in January Oh
congratulations very fun okay
and so whose kids are these we have a
lot of kids these are three of our five
this is Marsha she's four charlie is
nine and Erica sport all right very cool
all right so twenty nine and twenty
three you said mm-hmm okay now how long
did the twenty nine take well we engaged
on the Senate together in parallel so it
took us eight months altogether of the
whole beat each of you did it at the
same time yeah okay that works good okay
very cool and well I'm gonna break it
apart then and so Michael you you had
the 29 or the 23 at the 29 and how long
and what was your income during the
eight months a hundred and ninety K Wow
okay what do you do I'm an oncologist a
cancer doctor
oh okay very cool and Melissa paid off
twenty three and eight months with what
kind of an income 72 72 X on what do you
do I'm a scientist
and one of those evil college professors
that you fun very fun so what kind of
debt were these we were very normal we
had just about one of everything I had
died owed the IRS money I had credit
card I had a line of credit mm-hmm I had
a car loan mm-hmm and I had a student
loan uh student loan Oh Sallie Mae had
to kick her out very cool so obviously
you made plans to get married that might
have been part of the story and what
else prompted this eight months ago well
it was a college bill so
one of our daughters is not to here's in
college and went to a very expensive
school that I had not planned for well
at all we were visiting family and
trying to relax and this college bill
came due and I was on the phone during
this vacation talking to the college
begging them to give me ten more days to
come up with six thousand dollars mhm I
was making too much money to be broke
but I was broken I couldn't pay couldn't
pay my bills you know so I was dating
Melissa who'd been listening to you for
50 years mm-hmm
and I think you'd like this story she's
very crafty about it she she said well
you know just you can do this just we're
gonna focus everything you have we're
gonna stop paying in a retirement we're
gonna follow these simple rules and just
you know we can we can tackle this
didn't mention Dave Ramsey couldn't talk
about the baby steps I I didn't make
sense to me I was like I it seems you
know you're very smart lady so I trust
you I'm gonna go with you and then a
couple days later I looked over visiting
Melissa and I saw this Dave Ramsey book
sitting on the coffee table and I said
what's this and I pick it up and read it
and lo and behold that was the blueprint
that she had been very subtly getting to
me so I I discovered it all by myself
I learned the best way to get a man to
do something is to let him think it was
his idea on the table I'll just tell you
I was really embarrassed because I had
started listening to you when I was in
grad school I listened you every day at
3 o'clock when you were on and I knew
car payments were bad and credit card
was bad cuz that's what you were talking
about 15 years ago and then we revisited
jumpend your podcast now everybody with
student loans and I said wait a second I
have a student loan I'm not listening to
Dave Ramsey and so we just we scorched
the earth and and did it just knocked it
out well very cool this sets you up to
completely win with a new marriage very
fun well congratulations you two
very proud of it very proud of it we're
gonna give you each your own copy and
you'll be able to give one away of Chris
Hogan's a book signed Thank You number
one best seller retire inspired all
about building wealth because you're
gonna be able do that
this fabulous household income and no
debt and more than anything you know you
can work together now you'll be able to
do that that's perfect well
congratulations you two
thank you very very well done now the
three kids that are with you are what
ages and names marshes for charlie is
nine Eric's fourteen perfect alright and
have they been practicing
yeah they're pretty sound engineers want
to brace yourselves okay loud just put
on the special mics okay I love it very
cool all right Michael and Melissa Eric
Charlie and Marsha let's count it down
29,000 and 23,000 both paid off
individually in eight months and now
they're getting married in January
making 190 and making 72 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream my name
three two
well done you two very well done great
job that's how we do it man old man
that's the way you do it folks it's
exactly what the plan is and love it
love it love it love it love it very
well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common